This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. Often in life, we find ourselves wrestling with a decision. And when we do, we tend to focus on the outcome of that decision. How we'll feel once all is said and done. Will I love my new job or will I miss my old one? Should I move to a new city or stay close to friends and family? Will having children bring me joy or will they feel like a burden? We do this with smaller decisions too. Is this
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在生活中，我们常常会陷入纠结的决策中。而当我们这样做时，我们往往会关注决策的结果。关注当一切尘埃落定后，我们的感受会如何。我会喜欢我的新工作还是会怀念旧工作？我应该搬到一个新城市，还是留在亲朋好友身边？生孩子会给我带来快乐，还是会让我感到负担？我们在做小决定时也是如此。比如，这个
expensive vacation going to be worth the cost? Should I find a new preschool for my child? What major should I pursue in college? Our minds fill with questions as we try to predict the best paths to take. We make lists of pros and cons, weigh our options, get advice from friends. All this to make our future selves happy. But in running these mental calculations there's something we rarely consider about the future. We might not be the same person when we get there. Our future selves might think, feel, and value things differently than we do right now. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore one of life's trickiest questions.
昂贵的假期值得吗？我应该为孩子找一所新的幼儿园吗？我在大学里应该选什么专业？当我们试图预测最佳路径时，脑海中充满了各种问题。我们列出利弊清单，权衡各种选择，征求朋友的建议。这一切都是为了让未来的自己感到幸福。但在进行这些心理计算时，我们很少考虑到关于未来的某一点：当我们到达未来时，我们可能已经不是同一个人了。未来的我们可能会以不同于现在的方式思考、感受和评价事物。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将探讨人生中最棘手的问题之一。
How do we make decisions about the future, when we cannot anticipate who we'll be when we get there. Our lives are made up of experiences big and small. Some of these experiences flutter by, never to be thought of again, while others make lasting impressions. At Yale University, the philosopher Laurie Ann Paul, who is known as L.A. Paul, studies these experiences. She's interested in how they inform and transform who we are. L.A. Paul, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. I'm happy to be here.
当我们无法预知自己未来会成为什么样的人时，该如何做出关于未来的决定？我们的人生由大大小小的经历组成。有些经历转瞬即逝，再也不会被想起，而另一些则留下了深刻的印记。在耶鲁大学，哲学家劳里·安·保罗（Laurie Ann Paul，人称 L.A. Paul）专门研究这些经历。她对这些经历如何塑造和改变我们深感兴趣。L.A. Paul，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢，很高兴来到这里。
Laurie, in the middle of the 18th century, there was a young man named John Newton in England. His life story captures one aspect of this idea that you've been studying for a while. I understand he had a rather difficult upbringing. He was seen as a difficult child? Yes, and an important thing is that his mother died when he was very young. I mean I think this made him feel very unhappy and very alone, especially when his father remarried and basically sidelined John.
劳里，18世纪中叶，英国有一位名叫约翰·牛顿的年轻人。他的生平故事捕捉到了你研究已久的一个观点。据我了解，他的成长过程相当坎坷。他曾被视为一个问题儿童？是的，很重要的一点是，他的母亲在他很小的时候就去世了。我认为这让他感到非常痛苦和孤独，尤其是当他的父亲再婚并基本上冷落了约翰之后。
So his mother was religious, but after she died, John soon found himself not just turning away from religion, but turning against it. He became what you might call a militant atheist. Was his father a source of support, Laurie? No, well, his father was distant and unemotional and was focused heavily on self-discipline. So I suppose this was his father's way of supporting him, but John did not find it
他的母亲是一位虔诚的信徒，但在她去世后，约翰很快不仅背离了宗教，甚至开始反抗它。他成了你所说的“激进的无神论者”。劳里，他的父亲是他支持的来源吗？不，他的父亲冷漠且缺乏情感，非常注重自我约束。我想这可能是他父亲表达支持的方式，但约翰并没有觉得这
helpful. In fact, it alienated him both from his father and from other people. And his character also then started to deteriorate. He behaved badly, he was arrested, he was rebellious, he was publicly flogged, and he also importantly I think had this kind of experience of despair where he blamed others and wasn't able to kind of take responsibility for who he was and how he was behaving. So at one point he was recruited to join the Royal Navy, but even there he was rebellious and got punished for it. What do we know about his life at this point, Laurie? Okay, so I would say recruited is a good phrase.
有帮助。事实上，这让他与父亲以及其他人产生了隔阂。他的性格也随之开始恶化。他行为不端，被捕入狱，叛逆成性，还曾被公开鞭笞。我认为更重要的是，他经历了一种绝望，他责怪他人，无法为自己的身份和行为负责。后来他被征召加入皇家海军，但即使在那里，他依然叛逆并因此受到惩罚。劳里，关于他此时的生活，我们了解多少？好的，我想“征召”这个词用得不错。
He was press ganged by the Royal Navy. What happened was, I mean, so if you were a press gang, then you had, you were pressed into service as he was. He had some background with the sea, so he was especially valuable. But he wasn't obviously interested in hard work, and he wasn't a model seaman, shall we say. And at one point, what happened was he was traded basically to a slave ship. The Navy ships will exchange one set of seamen for another and this is what was happening. He clearly wasn't a very appealing member of the crew so he got swapped into a slave ship and this became then very formative for him because he entered the slave trade.
他被皇家海军强征入伍了。情况是这样的，如果你被强征，你就被迫服役，他就是这样。他有一些航海背景，所以他特别有价值。但他显然对辛苦工作不感兴趣，也不是我们所说的模范水手。后来，他基本上被转卖到了一艘奴隶船上。海军舰艇会交换水手，这就是当时发生的情况。他显然不是一个讨人喜欢的船员，所以他被换到了奴隶船上，这对他的影响非常深远，因为他从此进入了奴隶贸易行业。
So he finds himself working in the slave trade, and I understand even here he ends up making lots of enemies among the other men working on the slave ship. So basically, he was just not a very pleasant person to be around. That's right. I mean, well, for someone who doesn't want to be where they are, who doesn't have any kind of religious, shall we say, belief or faith to guide them to, I think, is alienated, unhappy. It's really no surprise that he was completely miserable.
所以他发现自己在从事奴隶贸易，据我了解，即使在那里，他也与船上的其他人结下了不少仇。基本上，他就是一个很难相处的人。没错。对于一个不想待在原地，又没有任何宗教信仰来指引自己的人来说，他感到疏离和不快乐，这真的不足为奇，他当时完全处于痛苦之中。
And then he also started to have serious health problems. So I think this added a certain kind of difficulty to his life. So at one point, John Newton gets left on the coast of Africa and and even the slave ship that he was on basically abandons him. He goes through various experiences and adventures but eventually finds himself back on a ship bound for England. This is called the Greyhound but far from being grateful to his rescuers he spends his days on the ship cursing and drinking,
后来，他开始出现严重的健康问题。我认为这让他的生活更加艰难。后来，约翰·牛顿被留在了非洲海岸，甚至他所在的奴隶船也基本上抛弃了他。他经历了各种各样的遭遇和冒险，但最终还是回到了前往英国的船上。这艘船叫“灰狗号”，但他对救命恩人毫无感激之情，在船上整天咒骂和酗酒，
and at one point even falls into the ocean and has to be rescued. So he's rescued, but that's right. He's not even, he hasn't repented, right? Even though he had a difficult time in Africa, he was badly treated, got himself into trouble. And in general, he sort of just went back to his old ways. And even this kind of near-miss didn't seem to have a significant effect. 監管局 On March 10, 1748, John Newton woke up in the night
甚至有一次掉进海里，不得不被救起。所以他被救了，但没错，他还没有悔改，对吧？尽管他在非洲度过了一段艰难的时光，受到了恶劣的对待，还惹上了麻烦。总的来说，他还是回到了老样子。即使是这种死里逃生的经历，似乎也没有产生显著的影响。1748年3月10日，约翰·牛顿在深夜醒来，
to find the ship was caught in a terrible storm. What did he do, Laurie? Well, okay, so a detail was that he happened to have with him a devotional text called the Imitation of Christ, and he had been reading it, okay? And this is before the storm. So this was something that he'd been reading as he was traveling.
发现船陷入了一场可怕的风暴中。劳里，他做了什么？好吧，有一个细节是，他当时随身带着一本名为《效法基督》的灵修书，他一直在读它，对吧？这是在风暴之前。所以这是他在旅途中一直在读的东西。
And then in the middle of the storm, right, he suddenly had the realization that, you know, not only was his life in danger and that the life of the entire crew was in danger, it was this incredibly intense situation, but he realized that if there was a God, he could expect no mercy. So he realized at the heart of this like incredibly frightening situation where, you know, imagine a small basically wooden boat being tossed around the sea with, you know, incredibly huge waves towering over it, like looking like, you know, knowing that at any moment death could come. And then, you know, at that moment you realize that you're in a position of vulnerability.
然后在风暴中，他突然意识到，不仅他的生命处于危险之中，整个船员的生命也危在旦夕。这是一种极其紧张的情况，但他意识到，如果真的有上帝，他将得不到任何怜悯。他意识到，在那种极其恐怖的情况下——想象一下，一艘小木船在海上被抛来抛去，巨大的海浪在它上方耸立，随时可能丧命——在那一刻，你意识到自己是多么脆弱。
And I think someone with religious faith would then look to God as a protector. And he realized both in that moment that he truly was vulnerable, but given his past life and his past way of being, that even in this moment of vulnerability, you know, he didn't deserve the kind of mercy that God would provide. The story goes that he and the captain of the ship had been plugging a hole, and this was after they had plugged many holes, but when they plugged this one, at one point he says, if this will not do, the Lord have mercy on us. And of course, at that point, he starts to reflect on the fact that he has, you know, railed against God for these many years, and what mercy could a sinner like him actually expect?
我想一个有宗教信仰的人会把上帝视为保护者。他在那一刻意识到自己确实很脆弱，但鉴于他过去的生活和处事方式，即使在这一脆弱时刻，他也不配得到上帝的怜悯。故事是这样的，他和船长一直在堵一个洞，这已经是在他们堵住许多洞之后了，但当他们堵住这个洞时，他有一次说：“如果这都不行，愿主怜悯我们。”当然，在那一刻，他开始反思自己多年来一直咒骂上帝的事实，像他这样的罪人到底能期待什么样的怜悯呢？
Yeah, exactly. So I think it's like, I think it's a combination of, you know, the realizing that, wait, I'm in trouble, but also for the first time maybe kind of comprehending what vulnerability requires. Seems to me that in this particular context, he was able, maybe for the first time, to realize what real vulnerability implied and also what the promise of being saved from that entailed. In other words, he was able to kind of see the appeal of religious belief maybe for the first time.
是的，完全正确。所以我认为这是一种结合，既意识到“天哪，我有麻烦了”，也可能第一次理解了脆弱意味着什么。在我看来，在这种特定的背景下，他可能第一次意识到真正的脆弱意味着什么，以及被拯救的承诺意味着什么。换句话说，他可能第一次看到了宗教信仰的吸引力。
So what happened? Did the ship survive the storm? So it did survive but I think an important element of that survival came from Newton because he took the helm for many hours and for most of a day and used this time, apparently, as he was basically attempting to kind of having the ship respond to the waves and dealing with all the problems of the storm, also reflected on his situation and who he was and what he was doing, what he had done, his past immorality, his past behavior, the way that he had isolated himself from other people and really had a bit of an existential crisis.
那么后来发生了什么？船在风暴中幸存下来了吗？是的，它幸存了下来，但我认为这种幸存的一个重要因素来自牛顿，因为他掌舵了许多小时，几乎是一整天。显然，他在试图让船应对海浪并处理风暴带来的所有问题时，也反思了自己的处境、自己的身份、自己的所作所为、过去的道德败坏、过去的行为，以及他如何将自己与他人隔绝，确实经历了一场存在主义危机。
As the storm subsided, he, I think, sort of also kind of emotionally collapsed. So the battered ship arrives in Ireland and only hours before a second major storm strikes, and in some ways convinces John Newton that God in fact answers prayers. And for the first time in many years, he visited a
随着风暴平息，我想他在情感上也崩溃了。这艘破损的船抵达爱尔兰，仅仅几个小时后，第二场大风暴就袭来了。这在某种程度上让约翰·牛顿相信，上帝确实会回应祈祷。多年来，他第一次走进
church and began to pray. That's right. So it seems like what happened was after experiencing this intense vulnerability and then in the midst of that, recognizing the power of being saved and sort of understanding like what that really meant and how in a moment of great openness you can be saved and sort of understanding like what that really meant and how in a moment of great openness, you can be saved. And recognizing that as in some sense, as the appeal of Christ. So I think he interprets this,
教堂，开始祈祷。没错。所以看起来发生的事情是，在经历了这种极度的脆弱，并在其中认识到被拯救的力量，理解了那意味着什么，以及在极度开放的时刻，你可以被拯救。并认识到这在某种意义上是基督的吸引力。所以我认为他解读为，
it seems like he interpreted this as a moment of insight, then he was allowed to then return to land and survive. And the ship gets back just before a second huge storm. So he feels like there was a sequence where he experienced a kind of openness and a recognition of the divine power and grace of God. He prays in response. God grants him then the opportunity to survive by getting him to land in time. After that, basically he starts going to church and kind of performing devotional services.
这似乎被他解读为一个顿悟的时刻，然后他被允许回到陆地并幸存下来。船在第二场大风暴来临前及时赶回。所以他觉得这是一个序列，他经历了一种开放，并认识到了神圣的力量和上帝的恩典。他以祈祷作为回应。上帝随后通过让他及时上岸，给了他生存的机会。在那之后，他基本上开始去教堂，并进行灵修服务。
So in 1772, this was a little more than two decades after that storm at sea, John Newton writes a hymn to describe his own transformation. Many of our listeners have heard this hymn, Laurie. What is it? It's Amazing Grace. So the hymn begins with amazing grace, how sweet the sound, that saved a wretch like me. I once was lost but now I'm found, was blind but now I see. Twas grace that taught my heart to fear and grace my fears relieved. How precious did that grace appear, the now I see. Twas grace that taught my heart to fear, and grace my fears relieved. How precious did that grace appear,
1772年，也就是那场海上风暴过去二十多年后，约翰·牛顿写了一首赞美诗来描述他自己的转变。劳里，我们的许多听众都听过这首赞美诗。是什么？是《奇异恩典》。这首赞美诗以“奇异恩典，何等甘甜，我罪已得赦免。前我失丧，今被寻回，瞎眼今得看见”开头。是恩典教导我的心去敬畏，也是恩典减轻了我的恐惧。那恩典显得何等珍贵，
the hour I first believed. And so you see it here, right? So here's this description, basically, of someone who's finding themselves really in a pit of despair, in darkness and lost, and who's gone through great pain and then suddenly is relieved from this fear and can see the beauty of what protection and love and goodness could bring.
在我初信的那一刻。所以你在这里看到了，对吧？这就是对一个发现自己陷入绝望深渊、处于黑暗和迷茫中，经历过巨大痛苦，然后突然从这种恐惧中解脱出来，并能看到保护、爱和善良所带来的美好的人的描述。
I'm wondering, Laurie, what the young John Newton, the rebellious man who was always cursing God and drinking himself senseless, what would he make of the older John Newton, the man we all now remember as the creator of Amazing Grace? Well, I think this is something that's very hard for any of us to make sense of. So anyone, certainly someone like John Newton, would view the future version of themselves that was kind of committed to a religious perspective as fundamentally unlike them because the way that they made sense of reality is fundamentally how they can make sense of reality. And I think would, you know, kind of reject that, you know, of course I wouldn't be like that.
劳里，我在想，年轻时的约翰·牛顿，那个总是咒骂上帝、喝得烂醉如泥的叛逆者，会如何看待年老的约翰·牛顿，那个我们现在都记得的《奇异恩典》的创作者？嗯，我认为这对我们任何一个人来说都很难理解。所以任何人，当然像约翰·牛顿这样的人，会认为未来那个致力于宗教视角的自己与现在的自己根本不同，因为他们理解现实的方式是根本性的。我想他会说：“当然，我不会变成那样。”
That's just not me. Another transformation that happened in John Newton's life is that he spent some time in the slave trade working on these slave ships, but eventually became an abolitionist and in some ways led the movement against the slave trade across the British Empire. Yes. This is another transformative experience,
“那根本不是我。”约翰·牛顿生命中发生的另一个转变是，他曾从事奴隶贸易，在奴隶船上工作，但最终成为了废奴主义者，并在某种程度上领导了整个大英帝国的反奴隶贸易运动。是的。这是另一种变革性的经历，
and I expect that it was related to his own discovery of both how one can be deeply vulnerable and how protection from the horrors of a problematic and violent world is so important. And my thought is that he participated in the slave trade, and he participated in some of the atrocities. And so I think he had a direct understanding of the kinds of, you know, individual and societal cruelties that were being imposed on people that were being enslaved.
我预计这与他自己发现一个人既可以极其脆弱，又发现从一个充满问题和暴力的世界的恐怖中获得保护是多么重要有关。我的想法是，他参与了奴隶贸易，并参与了一些暴行。所以我认为他直接了解了那些被奴役的人所遭受的个人和社会层面的残酷。
And I think to understand how terrible it is to be in a vulnerable position, I think one has to have experienced that. So if you've never experienced that kind of vulnerability, or maybe you've papered over it, I mean, he did lose his mother at a young age, and he was taught to kind of be a hard man and not be empathic and not think about himself
我认为要理解处于脆弱地位是多么可怕，一个人必须经历过。所以如果你从未经历过那种脆弱，或者你掩盖了它——我的意思是，他确实在年轻时失去了母亲，他被教导要成为一个坚硬的人，不要有同理心，不要考虑自己
or about others. But when he learned to think about himself and understand himself as a vulnerable person who needed saving, I think that what he discovered when he discovered, redemption and being saved himself from a watery grave was I think his capacity to understand that there might be other people who could also be vulnerable and needed saving. And so I like to think that his path basically to
或他人。但当他学会考虑自己，并将自己理解为一个需要拯救的脆弱的人时，我认为当他发现救赎并从水墓中被拯救出来时，他发现的是他理解可能还有其他人也同样脆弱并需要拯救的能力。所以我喜欢认为他通往
becoming an abolitionist was lighted by his ability to discover his own redemption and you know and to kind of find connection with with other people through that. At one point I understand he writes a pamphlet titled thoughts upon the African slavelave Trade, and it's a graphic account of what happens on these slave ships and includes a confession of his own involvement in the slave trade. I understand the pamphlet sells out, the second edition goes to every member of parliament. He ends up having a significant effect on the slave trade across the British Empire.
成为废奴主义者的道路，是由他发现自己救赎的能力所照亮的，并且通过这种方式与他人建立了联系。据我了解，他曾写过一本名为《关于非洲奴隶贸易的思考》的小册子，其中生动地描述了奴隶船上发生的事情，并包含了对自己参与奴隶贸易的忏悔。据我了解，这本小册子销售一空，第二版送到了每一位议员手中。他最终对整个大英帝国的奴隶贸易产生了重大影响。
Exactly. And so this is, I think, another version where he realizes how badly he had behaved. What he did was he drew from his own personal experience both what he did as a slave trader and what he saw as a slave trader, others doing, and recognized that he needed to confess. Okay, he needed to confess to his own sins and also describe the sins of others.
没错。所以我认为这是另一个版本，他意识到自己的行为有多么糟糕。他所做的是利用自己的个人经历，既包括他作为奴隶贩子的所作所为，也包括他作为奴隶贩子所看到的他人的行为，并认识到他需要忏悔。好吧，他需要忏悔自己的罪过，也要描述他人的罪过。
And obviously this is the same kind of thing that you see in other sorts of religious confessions of being a sinner. And was able to, I think, demonstrate through implicating himself in the truthfulness of his account and also the cruelty and outrageousness of what was being done. So he was able, I think, through the pamphlet,
显然，这和你在其他宗教忏悔中看到的作为罪人的忏悔是一样的。我认为他能够通过将自己牵连进他叙述的真实性中，以及所作所为的残酷和令人发指，来证明这一点。所以我认为他通过这本小册子，
to bring home in a particular way the outrages that were being perpetrated and to show the immoral nature of the practice. And this made, I think, a significant contribution to the political movement to abolish slavery in England. John Newton went from being a man who loved to stir up trouble to a minister who tended to other troublemakers. He went from profiting off the slave trade to an outspoken opponent of it. He died nine months after the slave trade
以一种特殊的方式揭示了正在实施的暴行，并展示了这种做法的不道德本质。我认为这为英国废除奴隶制的政治运动做出了重大贡献。约翰·牛顿从一个喜欢惹是生非的人变成了一位照顾其他麻烦制造者的牧师。他从奴隶贸易中获利，变成了它的直言不讳的反对者。他在奴隶贸易被废除九个月后去世了
was abolished across the British Empire. We've all had experiences that have had profound effects on us. Sometimes those experiences are big, like witnessing a birth or surviving catastrophe. And sometimes they are small, like meeting a friend who offers us a new point of view. When we come back, how life-altering events reshape who we are they are small, like meeting a friend who offers us a new point of view.
整个大英帝国。我们都经历过对我们产生深远影响的经历。有时这些经历很大，比如见证出生或在灾难中幸存。有时它们很小，比如遇到一个为我们提供新视角的朋友。当我们回来时，我们将探讨改变人生的事件如何重塑我们。
When we come back, how life-altering events reshape who we are, and the psychological challenge of dealing with such change. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We spend a lot of time trying to make plans for our future selves. That is, the version of ourselves that will exist tomorrow, next week or a year from now. We make these plans based on the assumption that we are going to be the same person tomorrow, next week, or a year from now. But what if this is not the case? What if our
当我们回来时，我们将探讨改变人生的事件如何重塑我们，以及应对这种变化的心理挑战。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们花了很多时间试图为未来的自己做计划。也就是说，为明天、下周或一年后存在的那个版本的自己做计划。我们基于这样一个假设来制定这些计划：即我们明天、下周或一年后将是同一个人。但如果事实并非如此呢？如果我们的
future self is a stranger to us? At Yale University, the philosopher L.A. Paul explores this question. Laurie, just like John Newton, the philosopher L.A. Paul explores this question. Laurie, just like John Newton, the activist Malcolm X also had a number of transformative experiences. Can you give us a quick biographical sketch and how these experiences changed him? Yes, so okay so it depends on where we want to start. I think he had experiences as a child when his father was killed and his mother was committed basically to a mental institution. I think that was very traumatic for him. He had an experience when he was in school where he was told he couldn't become a lawyer because he was black. And as he developed and grew, he was imprisoned. So he engaged in some
未来的自己对我们来说是个陌生人呢？在耶鲁大学，哲学家L.A. Paul探讨了这个问题。劳里，就像约翰·牛顿一样，活动家马尔科姆·X也经历过许多变革性的经历。你能给我们做一个简短的传记概述，以及这些经历是如何改变他的吗？是的，这取决于我们想从哪里开始。我认为他在童年时期经历过父亲被杀、母亲被送进精神病院的事情。我认为这对他是非常创伤性的。他在学校时曾经历过因为是黑人而被告知不能成为律师。随着他的成长，他入狱了。他参与了一些
burglaries and was caught and then he was imprisoned. But when he was incarcerated, he discovered basically the beauty of reading. And there's a quote where he describes months passing without even thinking about his imprisonment, that he had never felt so the beauty of reading. And there's a quote where he describes months passing without even thinking about his imprisonment that he had never felt so truly free in his life. And so what happened basically is Malcolm X sort of embarks on this very kind of literary and intellectual process of kind of self-development.
入室盗窃并被捕，随后入狱。但在服刑期间，他发现了阅读的美妙。有一句名言描述了几个月过去，他甚至没有想到自己的监禁，他从未感到如此……阅读的美妙。有一句名言描述了几个月过去，他甚至没有想到自己的监禁，他从未感到如此
And at the same time, he becomes exposed to the nation of Islam and becomes basically a kind of minister-development, and at the same time, he becomes exposed to the nation of Islam and becomes basically a kind of minister with the group. And at this point, I think many people are familiar with the speeches he made where he preaches violence as a solution to oppression, and he transforms himself basically from being this troubled kid to someone who basically says, you know,
真正自由。所以发生的事情基本上是马尔科姆·X踏上了一种非常文学和知识性的自我发展过程。同时，他接触到了伊斯兰民族组织，并基本上成为了该组织的一名部长。在这一点上，我想许多人都熟悉他发表的演讲，他在演讲中宣扬暴力是解决压迫的方案，他基本上将自己从一个问题少年转变为一个基本上说，你知道，
violence is the way to rid ourselves of the shackles of oppression. himself basically from being this troubled kid to someone who basically says, you know, violence is the way to rid ourselves of the shackles of oppression. That's right. And bring about the freedom of these people by any means necessary. So what he does is he comes into himself as a deeply, I think, intellectual and powerful and motivating speaker supporting black emancipation and the black power movement. And he's very critical then, of course, of like the civil rights movement and Martin Luther King, because these are nonviolent advocates of a nonviolent
暴力是摆脱压迫枷锁的方式。他基本上将自己从一个问题少年转变为一个基本上说，你知道，暴力是摆脱压迫枷锁的方式。没错。并以任何必要手段实现这些人的自由。所以他所做的是，他成为了一名深刻的、我认为是知识渊博、强大且具有激励作用的演讲者，支持黑人解放和黑人权力运动。当然，他非常批评民权运动和马丁·路德·金，因为他们是非暴力倡导者，主张以非暴力
way of achieving civil rights. And he thought this was kind of, you know, not powerful enough, right? Like he didn't want to fight against racial segregation. He wanted to defend racial segregation as the best way to kind of preserve true emancipation. Instead of you and me running around here seeking allies in our struggle for freedom, in the Irish neighborhood or the Jewish neighborhood or the Italian neighborhood, we need to, we need to seek some allies among people who look something like we do. Once we get there, allies.
方式实现民权。他认为这不够强大，对吧？他不想反对种族隔离。他想捍卫种族隔离，认为这是保持真正解放的最佳方式。与其让你我在爱尔兰社区、犹太社区或意大利社区寻找争取自由的盟友，我们不如在那些看起来和我们差不多的人中寻找盟友。一旦我们到达那里，盟友。
So in 1963 he goes on a pilgrimage to Mecca, one of the holiest sites of Islam. How did this pilgrimage change him, Laurie? He goes on a pilgrimage to Mecca, one of the holiest sites of Islam. How did this pilgrimage change him, Laurie? When he goes on the pilgrimage, he discovers that there are Muslims of all different races. He describes seeing Muslims of all colors, from blue-eyed blondes to black-skinned Africans, basically interacting as equals. Everybody was interested in the same kind of spiritual development. Everyone was making this pilgrimage.
1963年，他去麦加朝圣，这是伊斯兰教最神圣的地方之一。这次朝圣是如何改变他的，劳里？他去麦加朝圣，这是伊斯兰教最神圣的地方之一。这次朝圣是如何改变他的，劳里？当他去朝圣时，他发现有各种种族的穆斯林。他描述看到各种肤色的穆斯林，从蓝眼睛的金发碧眼者到黑皮肤的非洲人，基本上平等地互动。每个人都对同样的灵性发展感兴趣。每个人都在进行这次朝圣。
And he discovered through having this experience, it wasn't something that he could think of or conceive of, given his previous experience in the U.S. and how badly he and his family had been treated by white people on a very consistent basis. Also, other members of the Nation of Islam, like there were lots of terrible interactions with white police members in particular. But this experience opened up like a new framework for him where he thought, well, I see a way
通过这次经历，他发现这并不是他根据在美国的先前经历所能想到或构想出来的，因为他和他的家人一直受到白人的恶劣对待。此外，伊斯兰民族组织的其他成员，比如与白人警察成员之间有很多可怕的互动。但这次经历为他打开了一个新的框架，他想，好吧，我看到了
in which Islam could provide a means to kind of overcome racial problems. In other words, it opened up a conceptual space for him that allowed him then to change his perspective and to think that maybe you didn't have to think that white people were devils. You didn't have to have this kind of deeply exclusionary kind of worldview. And so he comes back to the United States and how does this change the message that he's preaching? It's quite disruptive. He changes his worldview, he changes his message, he starts to rethink the question of racial justice and how to kind of get there.
伊斯兰教可以提供一种克服种族问题的方法。换句话说，它为他打开了一个概念空间，使他能够改变自己的观点，并认为也许你不必认为白人是魔鬼。你不必拥有这种深刻的排他性世界观。所以他回到美国，这如何改变了他宣扬的信息？这非常具有颠覆性。他改变了自己的世界观，改变了自己的信息，开始重新思考种族正义的问题以及如何实现它。
First, the white men and the black men have to be able to sit down at the same table. The white man has to feel free to speak his mind without hurting the feelings of that Negro. And the so-called Negro has to feel free to speak his mind without hurting the feelings of the white man. Then they can bring the issues that are under the rug out on top the table and take an intelligent approach to get the problem solved. So you call the turns in Malcolm X's life, the turns that we all experience as we go through life, transformative experiences. What do you mean by that term, Laurie? What I mean by the phrase transformative experience is an experience that results from discovering a new kind of
首先，白人和黑人必须能够坐在同一张桌子旁。白人必须感到可以自由表达自己的想法，而不伤害那个黑人的感情。所谓的黑人也必须感到可以自由表达自己的想法，而不伤害白人的感情。然后他们可以把地毯下的问题拿到桌面上，采取明智的方法来解决问题。所以你把马尔科姆·X生命中的转折，也就是我们每个人在生活中经历的转折，称为变革性经历。劳里，你所说的这个词是什么意思？我所说的“变革性经历”是指通过发现一种新的
experience. In other words, having a kind of experience that you've never had before that's also very distinctive. I mean, you can have a new kind of experience like, you know, tasting a new esoteric flavor of jelly bean and it might not change anything radical. But some new kinds of experiences are very profound. They, you know, they teach us something new that basically reorganizes the way that we make sense of the world and ourselves in relationship to it. Can you talk a moment about how these transformative
体验而产生的经历。换句话说，拥有某种你从未有过的、也非常独特的经历。我的意思是，你可以有某种新的经历，比如品尝一种新的深奥口味的软糖，它可能不会改变任何激进的东西。但一些新的经历是非常深刻的。它们教给我们一些新的东西，基本上重组了我们理解世界以及我们与世界关系的方式。你能谈谈这些变革性
experiences are not just something external happening to us, but they're also a way for us to discover something about ourselves that perhaps we did not know earlier? Yes, so if it's a new kind of experience, then I think of you learning something new or gaining a new ability to represent the world or to think about yourself as interacting with the world. And so you can learn something about yourself through that experience by
经历不仅仅是发生在外部的事情，它们也是我们发现一些我们以前可能不知道的关于自己的事情的一种方式吗？是的，如果是某种新的经历，那么我认为是你学习到了新东西，或者获得了代表世界或思考自己与世界互动的新能力。所以你可以通过那种经历了解关于自己的一些事情，通过
learning that you have new abilities to respond in ways that you didn't realize that you had. But you can also create those new abilities in virtue of having the experience. Say you were blind and had a retina operation and gained the ability to see. You would gain all kinds of new abilities, but partly in virtue of having these new sensory experiences. You told us the story earlier of John Newton, and I'm thinking about what happened to him the night of that storm. You know, he has this terrible catastrophe
学习到你拥有以前没有意识到的应对新能力。但你也可以通过拥有这种经历来创造这些新能力。假设你失明了，做了视网膜手术并获得了视力。你会获得各种各样的新能力，但部分原因是由于拥有了这些新的感官体验。你之前给我们讲了约翰·牛顿的故事，我在想那天晚上风暴中发生在他身上的事情。你知道，他有一场可怕的灾难
unfolding around him, but in the process, he's also realizing something about himself. He's realizing that he is vulnerable, that he is scared, that he is calling upon God for mercy. In some ways the storm is revealing something that's inside him to him. It's interesting. So there's the new experience there is first the experience of incredible danger and I'm sure the power of the storm was also like, you know, the amount of force that he must have experienced with the waves must have been kind of overwhelming. I'm sure that,
在他周围展开，但在过程中，他也意识到了一些关于自己的事情。他意识到自己是脆弱的，他是害怕的，他在呼求上帝的怜悯。在某种程度上，风暴正在向他揭示他内心深处的东西。这很有趣。所以那里有新的经历，首先是难以置信的危险的经历，我相信风暴的力量也像，你知道，他一定经历过的海浪的力量一定是压倒性的。我相信，
you know, you wouldn't normally experience that. So he has this new kind of experience, and this brings home to him his vulnerability in a way that it seems like he probably hasn't experienced since he was a child. And so so you're right. So there's this external experience, the storm that then creates a response in him, which is, I think, a new kind of feeling, a new capacity for vulnerability. And then what he discovers in himself is he feels this vulnerability. And what does he do? He hopes for grace. He hopes for redemption. He hopes that the Lord will take mercy on
你通常不会经历那种事情。所以他有了这种新的经历，这让他以一种他似乎自童年以来就没有经历过的方式感受到了自己的脆弱。所以你是对的。所以有这种外部经历，风暴，然后在他身上创造了一种反应，我认为这是一种新的感觉，一种新的脆弱能力。然后他在自己身上发现的是，他感受到了这种脆弱。他做了什么？他希望得到恩典。他希望得到救赎。他希望主会怜悯
him. And he then also discovers then this kind of latent desire to be saved. In both the examples of John Newton and Malcolm X, we see a person transforming into someone they would have considered antithetical to their younger selves. These are examples of dramatic transformations. They underscore the challenge that Laurie has been studying. Why do we think we can confidently make plans for our future selves, when in fact, we might have very different preferences, attitudes, and values in the future. Laurie says that you don't need dramatic moments of transformation to see how subjective
他。然后他还发现了这种潜在的被拯救的渴望。在约翰·牛顿和马尔科姆·X的例子中，我们都看到一个人转变成了一个他们年轻时会认为是反面的人。这些是戏剧性转变的例子。它们强调了劳里一直在研究的挑战。为什么我们认为我们可以自信地为未来的自己制定计划，而事实上，我们在未来可能会有非常不同的偏好、态度和价值观。劳里说，你不需要戏剧性的转变时刻就能看到主观
experience can reshape our minds. She cites a thought experiment, first proposed by the Australian philosopher Frank Cameron Jackson, about a brilliant scientist named Mary, who has a very odd upbringing. In Jackson's thought experiment, the idea is that Mary grows up in a black and white environment. She's, she's never been in anything other than a black and white space. And her skin is painted either black or white, whichever you prefer so that she doesn't have, she's never had any experience of color. Now in Jackson's example, she's also a scientist who knows all of the science of
体验如何重塑我们的思想。她引用了一个思想实验，最初由澳大利亚哲学家弗兰克·卡梅伦·杰克逊提出，关于一位名叫玛丽的杰出科学家，她有着非常奇怪的成长经历。在杰克逊的思想实验中，观点是玛丽在一个黑白环境中长大。她从未处于黑白空间之外的任何地方。她的皮肤被涂成黑色或白色，随你喜欢，这样她就没有，她从未有过任何色彩的体验。现在在杰克逊的例子中，她也是一位科学家，了解所有关于
color and the science of the brain so that she knows basically you know all the scientific facts about what seeing color involves. And we can even add to it that maybe other people who know about color tell her about kind of you know what color is like this and red, you know, red is like warm water and blue, you know, blue is like cold water and fire engines are painted red and that sort of thing. So she has all this information, but she's never left her black and white space. And then the question that Jackson asks is, well, Mary knows all this information. Does she know what it's like to see red? And the thought experiment is designed in such a way that we're supposed to say, and most people do say this, and I certainly think this, and most philosophers think this, that no, Mary doesn't know what it's like to see red.
色彩和大脑的科学，所以她基本上知道关于看到颜色涉及的所有科学事实。我们甚至可以补充说，也许其他了解颜色的人告诉她关于颜色是什么样的，红色就像温水，蓝色就像冷水，消防车被漆成红色等等。所以她拥有所有这些信息，但她从未离开过她的黑白空间。然后杰克逊提出的问题是，好吧，玛丽知道所有这些信息。她知道看到红色是什么感觉吗？这个思想实验的设计方式是，我们应该说，大多数人确实这么说，我当然也这么认为，大多数哲学家也这么认为，不，玛丽不知道看到红色是什么感觉。
She knows all the scientific facts about seeing red, but that's just not enough. She has to actually leave her black and white space and go out into the world and see red for herself to know. And once she's done that, then she'll know what it's like to see red. Then she can add that to her scientific knowledge. But that's a different thing over and above all of the scientific facts. And is the different thing merely subjective experience, which is at this point Mary being a brilliant scientist has learned everything about wavelengths and frequencies. She knows all the physics of light. She knows the properties of red. She knows what things are red. She has had the color red described to her in
她知道关于看到红色的所有科学事实，但这还不够。她必须真正离开她的黑白空间，走到外面的世界，亲自看到红色才能知道。一旦她这样做了，她就会知道看到红色是什么感觉。然后她可以将其添加到她的科学知识中。但这与所有科学事实是不同的东西。那么这个不同的东西仅仅是主观体验吗？此时玛丽作为一名杰出的科学家，已经了解了关于波长和频率的一切。她知道光的所有物理学。她知道红色的属性。她知道哪些东西是红色的。她已经在
various settings. What has changed when she finally sees red for herself for the first time? Right, so in Jackson's example he assumes that we're at the end of all scientific inquiry. So there are no new scientific facts to learn. And Jackson wants to say, well, maybe there's something else to learn about the world that's more than just all the scientific facts in virtue of having a subjective experience. Learn a way that the first person perspective
各种环境中被描述过红色。当她最终第一次亲自看到红色时，发生了什么变化？对，所以在杰克逊的例子中，他假设我们处于所有科学探究的终点。所以没有新的科学事实可以学习。杰克逊想说，好吧，也许通过拥有主观体验，还有其他关于世界的东西可以学习，而不仅仅是所有的科学事实。学习一种第一人称视角
or the mind meets the world. And that's just not something that you can capture with a kind of third-person, objective scientific point of view. I mean, Malcolm X had probably read accounts of what people traveling to Mecca experienced, right? He might have read about what this pilgrimage was like, but of course, that's not the same thing
或心灵与世界相遇的方式。这并不是你可以用第三人称、客观的科学视角所能捕捉到的东西。我的意思是，马尔科姆·X可能读过关于去麦加朝圣的人的经历，对吧？他可能读过这次朝圣是什么样的，但当然，那不是
as actually going on the pilgrimage himself. Exactly. And I think also seeing people performing various acts together and seeing people kind of exercise a kind of devotional revelation is very powerful. He probably responded empathically as well. And so you could know all the science of like empathic response. And still once you feel that, that's going to be motivationally different. So it's that kind of thing that I want to pinpoint. I want to say that yeah, Malcolm X probably knew in theory he would meet people of all different races, right? But when he actually did and interacted with them, he saw that there was a capacity for something and was motivated to sort of change his way of thinking in a way that maybe he just, you know, physically wouldn't have been able to do if he hadn't had that actual experience.
亲自去朝圣。没错。而且我认为看到人们一起进行各种行为，看到人们行使某种灵性启示是非常强大的。他可能也做出了同理心的反应。所以你可以知道关于同理心反应的所有科学知识。但一旦你感受到了，那在动机上就会有所不同。所以我想要指出的就是那种东西。我想说，是的，马尔科姆·X可能在理论上知道他会遇到各种种族的人，对吧？但当他真正遇到并与他们互动时，他看到了一种可能性的存在，并被激励去改变他的思维方式，以一种如果他没有那种实际经历，他可能在物理上就无法做到的方式。
At a much more trivial level, this might involve the foods we eat, for example, the fruits we eat, for example. If there's something that we haven't tasted before, just having it described to us doesn't quite do it justice. That's right. My favorite case is the example of the durian fruit because at least many people who live in the US, which is where I live, have never tasted a durian. And the durian fruit is very strange because it's both incredibly foul smelling, but the taste, independently of the smell, is supposed to be something like, I don't know, strawberry vanilla custard or something like that. And so if you haven't tasted it, I can tell you it's like having a strawberry vanilla custard next to a sewer, and that's pretty evocative, or
在一个更琐碎的层面上，这可能涉及我们吃的食物，例如，我们吃的水果。如果有什么我们以前没尝过的东西，仅仅让它被描述给我们听并不能完全体现它的价值。没错。我最喜欢的例子是榴莲，因为至少许多住在美国（我住的地方）的人从未尝过榴莲。榴莲非常奇怪，因为它既有令人难以置信的恶臭，但味道（独立于气味）据说像草莓香草奶油冻之类的东西。所以如果你没尝过，我可以告诉你，这就像在下水道旁边吃草莓香草奶油冻，这很形象，或者
it's like eating stinky cheese, but you still don't know what it tastes like. That's just an evocative description. So there's a real world example that comes to mind that perhaps has slightly bigger stakes than eating a fruit, Laurie, and that's the decision to have children. Talk about this, that we can read books about what it's like to have children, what it's like to raise children, but that's not quite the same thing as actually having a child yourself. No, I think that's right.
这就像吃臭奶酪，但你仍然不知道它是什么味道。那只是一个形象的描述。所以有一个现实世界的例子浮现在脑海中，也许比吃水果的风险稍微大一点，劳里，那就是生孩子的决定。谈谈这个，我们可以读关于生孩子是什么感觉、抚养孩子是什么感觉的书，但这与亲自生孩子并不完全一样。不，我认为那是对的。
This is exactly what happened to me when I had my first child. So I became pregnant and the pregnancy was already a series of discoveries. In other words, what it was like to grow a person inside of you was both something that's exhaustively discussed in various contexts and also completely impossible to understand until you've actually had that happen. And even more so with the process of giving birth. There's something utterly bizarre about knowing that you're growing a child inside you. There's something utterly bizarre about having to kind of get that child outside of your body because it's far too big as you realize in a very important
这正是我生第一个孩子时所经历的。我怀孕了，而怀孕本身就是一系列的发现。换句话说，在体内孕育一个生命的感觉，既是在各种语境下被详尽讨论的话题，也是在亲身经历之前完全无法理解的事情。分娩的过程更是如此。知道自己体内正在孕育一个孩子，这本身就极其离奇。而不得不把那个孩子从体内弄出来，因为正如你在即将临盆时以一种非常重要且深刻的方式所意识到的那样，它实在太大了，这同样极其离奇。
and profound way when you're, when it's about to happen. And then also the transition from this child that you've known from the inside, moving inside you, to seeing the baby after the birth is, it's profound. You know, You know this child in one way, and then you meet this child after you push it out of your body. It's just not something that you can understand unless you actually go through that experience. That was a really enlightening moment for me,
从你从内部了解、感受其胎动的孩子，到出生后见到婴儿，这种转变是深刻的。你知道，你以一种方式了解这个孩子，然后当你把它从体内推出来后，你又见到了它。除非你亲身经历，否则你无法理解。那对我来说是一个非常有启发性的时刻，
precisely because I saw the connection between that and the trivial experience of like seeing red for the first time or trying a durian for the first time because I thought wait a minute The same structure is here But this experience it's so profound and so moving that it's really changed something about me in a very fundamental way You once wrote a paper on this topic what you can't expect when you're expecting, and it's about this gap between what parenthood is like as you read about it and think about
正是因为我看到了这一点与诸如第一次看到红色或第一次尝试榴莲这种琐碎经历之间的联系，因为我想，等一下，同样的结构在这里。但这种经历是如此深刻和动人，以至于它在非常根本的层面上改变了我。你曾经写过一篇关于这个主题的论文，题目是《当你期待时你不能期待什么》，它讲述了关于为人父母的阅读与思考，与实际体验之间的差距。
it and actually then experiencing it. That's right. And part of the title is a play on a famous book called What to Expect When You're Expecting. And I read that book and I was so disappointed because it didn't tell me at all what to expect when I was expecting. And I read that book and I was so disappointed because it didn't tell me at all what to expect when I was expecting. I remember getting so frustrated that I threw it against the wall. And so that's why I had to write a paper in response after going through the process of pregnancy and giving birth and realizing that it was profoundly different from anything that
没错。标题的一部分是对一本名为《当你期待时你会期待什么》的著名书籍的戏仿。我读了那本书，但我非常失望，因为它根本没有告诉我当我怀孕时该期待什么。我读了那本书，但我非常失望，因为它根本没有告诉我当我怀孕时该期待什么。我记得我当时非常沮丧，以至于把它扔到了墙上。所以这就是为什么在经历了怀孕和分娩的过程，并意识到它与任何人通过证言或书本所能描述给我的内容截然不同之后，我不得不写一篇论文来回应。
anyone could have described to me through a testimony, um, or in the pages of a book. When I say I'm not the same person, what I mean is that what I care about most in this world has changed as a result of the transformation, right? I care most about, you know, my children and that's made me into a different kind of person. And so the testimony you're getting to me, you're getting from me now about how great it is to be a parent doesn't apply to the person who's, like, to me before I ever even thought about having a child.
当我说我不再是同一个人时，我的意思是，由于这种转变，我在这个世界上最关心的事情已经改变了，对吧？我最关心的是我的孩子们，这使我成为了一个不同的人。所以，你现在从我这里得到的关于为人父母有多棒的证言，并不适用于那个甚至从未想过要生孩子的我。
I didn't care about those things. When we come back, deeper problems with not knowing who our future selves are going to be. Also, Laurie asks me to imagine a rather unusual scenario. I ask us to imagine ourselves, or ask you to imagine yourself, traveling on summer vacation, exploring a castle and going deep into the dungeons when Dracula comes to you. And he offers to make you into a vampire. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In life, we very often don't anticipate how much we will change in the future.
我那时并不关心这些事情。稍后回来，我们将探讨关于不知道未来自己会变成什么样的人的更深层问题。此外，劳里让我想象一个相当不寻常的场景。我请我们想象一下，或者请你想象一下，在暑假旅行，探索一座城堡，深入地牢时，德古拉来到了你面前。他提出要把你变成吸血鬼。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在生活中，我们往往没有预料到未来我们会发生多大的变化。
Sure, we may understand that going through a midlife crisis, or having a child, or falling in love, will have some effect on us. But we do not expect these experiences to upend who we are at a fundamental level. The philosopher L.A. Paul is the author of the book, Transformative Experience. She says the people we were before those experiences may not be the people we become afterwards. How do we plan for the future, when our future selves might be strangers? And what does this mean for how we should live our lives in the here and now? Laurie, one thing we try and do as we are making important decisions is that we try
当然，我们可能明白经历中年危机、生孩子或坠入爱河会对我们产生一些影响。但我们并没有预料到这些经历会从根本上颠覆我们是谁。哲学家L.A.保罗是《变革性体验》一书的作者。她说，我们在经历这些之前的人，可能不再是我们之后变成的人。当我们未来的自己可能是陌生人时，我们该如何为未来做计划？这对我们应该如何活在当下意味着什么？劳里，我们在做重要决定时尝试做的一件事是，我们尝试
to simulate how we will feel if we went down path A or path B. How effective is simulation in helping us anticipate how we will feel after a decision? I do think that we rely on simulation in lots of contexts and I think it can be very effective when we're relying on simulation of things that are familiar to us or for example trying to kind of put together simulations of combinations that are familiar to us. So maybe I've never had coconut coffee ice cream, but I can imagine the flavors mixed together and probably could get a pretty good simulation.
模拟如果我们走A路径或B路径会感觉如何。模拟在帮助我们预测决定后的感受方面有多有效？我确实认为我们在许多语境下都依赖模拟，而且我认为当我们依赖于我们熟悉的事物，或者例如尝试将我们熟悉的组合拼凑在一起进行模拟时，它可能非常有效。所以也许我从未吃过椰子咖啡冰淇淋，但我可以想象这些味道混合在一起，可能能得到一个相当不错的模拟。
But when we try to simulate ourselves as being very different, I think there are like two really serious problems that we have there. The first one is related to the problem of this example of where Mary, who grows up in a black and white room and has never seen color, can't imagine what it's like to see color, doesn't know what it's like to see red until she actually goes out and has the experience. If you ask Mary to simulate what it's
但当我们试图模拟自己变得非常不同时，我认为我们面临两个非常严重的问题。第一个问题与玛丽的例子有关，她在一个黑白房间里长大，从未见过颜色，无法想象看到颜色是什么感觉，直到她真正走出去并有了这种经历，她才知道看到红色是什么感觉。如果你让玛丽模拟
like to see red before she's ever had that experience, I just don't think she could do it. I think she might simulate something, but I just don't think it would be accurate. So the first problem is that our ability to simulate is, I think, just kind of limited in certain ways by our experiences and maybe by the capacity of the human mind. I mean, it might just not be possible to simulate truly great pain if you ever haven't had it like the pain of giving birth or something like that. But there's another problem as well.
在从未有过那种经历之前看到红色是什么感觉，我只是不认为她能做到。我认为她可能会模拟出一些东西，但我只是不认为那是准确的。所以第一个问题是，我认为我们的模拟能力在某些方面受到我们经历的限制，也许也受到人类思维能力的限制。我的意思是，如果你从未经历过，可能根本无法模拟出真正巨大的痛苦，比如分娩的痛苦之类的。但还有另一个问题。
The other problem has to do with what I think of as the kind of conceptual revolution that we undergo when we change the kind of person that we are. So going back to when we were talking about religious conversion, I think that John Newton as well as Malcolm X each underwent a kind of conceptual revolution in how they made sense either of the world or of the possibility of God or of the capacity for people of other races to embrace a shared goal. Okay. And in all of these contexts, Okay. And in all of these contexts, the kind of conceptual revolution that they underwent may be similar to like the Copernican revolution, right? In other words, a real change in how you understood like the nature of the world also changed like how they understood themselves and who they were. And there's another philosophy example that I've been thinking about a lot recently.
另一个问题与我所认为的当我们改变我们所属的人的类型时所经历的那种概念革命有关。回到我们谈论宗教皈依的时候，我认为约翰·牛顿和马尔科姆·X在他们理解世界、上帝的可能性，或者其他人种的人拥抱共同目标的能力方面，都经历了一种概念革命。好的。而在所有这些语境中，好的。而在所有这些语境中，他们所经历的那种概念革命可能类似于哥白尼革命，对吧？换句话说，你对世界本质的理解发生了真正的改变，也改变了他们对自身以及他们是谁的理解。还有另一个我最近一直在思考的哲学例子。
It's another famous one developed by Thomas Nagel, or at least popularized by Thomas Nagel, about imagining the possibility of being a bat. And what Nagel says is, look, it's just not possible for a person to imagine or to know what it's like to be a bat. And now that sounds a lot like the Mary in the black and white room example, but there's something extra that Nagel says that I think is really important.
这是托马斯·内格尔提出的，或者至少是由托马斯·内格尔推广的另一个著名例子，关于想象成为一只蝙蝠的可能性。内格尔说的是，看，一个人不可能想象或知道成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉。现在这听起来很像黑白房间里的玛丽的例子，但内格尔说的还有一些额外的东西，我认为这非常重要。
Nagel says, sure, you can imagine having wings and flapping upside down and maybe detecting sound through echolocation, the way that human beings do it when they hear someone walking down a corridor. But that's not imagining what it's like for a bat to be a bat. That's imagining a human version walking down a corridor. But that's not imagining what it's like for a bat to be a bat. That's imagining a human version of being a bat. And what he's trying to get at there
内格尔说，当然，你可以想象长出翅膀、倒挂着拍打翅膀，也许像人类听到有人走过走廊那样通过回声定位来探测声音。但那并不是在想象成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉。那是在想象一个人类版本走过走廊。但那并不是在想象成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉。那是在想象一个人类版本的蝙蝠。而他试图表达的是
is that there's a kind of conceptual incoherence in imagining yourself as someone else. And it's just, there's a way in which you just can't do it. On the one hand, there's this kind of inconceivability of it. On the other hand, you don't even know the nature of the change that's supposed to bring this about. And so you can't even kind of perform some kind of educated kind of forward evolution
想象自己是别人存在一种概念上的不连贯性。而且，在某种程度上你就是做不到。一方面，这有一种不可构想性。另一方面，你甚至不知道应该导致这种改变的本质是什么。所以你甚至无法对这种改变将如何发生进行某种有根据的前瞻性演变。
of how that change would happen. So when we make big decisions, we often come up with lists of pros and cons. Effectively, we're doing a cost-benefit analysis. You have a thought experiment to illustrate this idea that involves vampires. Can you describe the thought experiment for us? Sure. This is my favorite thought experiment. So I ask us to imagine ourselves, or ask you
所以当我们做重大决定时，我们经常列出利弊清单。实际上，我们是在做成本效益分析。你有一个思想实验来说明这个想法，涉及吸血鬼。你能为我们描述一下这个思想实验吗？当然。这是我最喜欢的思想实验。所以我请我们想象一下，或者请你
to imagine yourself, traveling on summer vacation somewhere in Romania, exploring a castle and going deep into the dungeons when Dracula comes to you. He offers to make you into a vampire. And this is a very, you know, this is a rather stunning development in your summer vacation. So you rush back to your Airbnb and you start thinking about what do I want to do? And before you left, Dracula said to you, look, leave your window open at midnight and I will come to you. Otherwise, in the morning, leave and never, never return. It's like this is an ear. This is a one time only only choice and if you become a vampire, you can never go back. So as you reflect, you start looking up information about vampires and you start calling your friends and talking to them about it and you find out that all of them have already become vampires. And so of course, after getting upset with them
想象一下，在暑假去罗马尼亚某处旅行，探索一座城堡，深入地牢时，德古拉来到了你面前。他提出要把你变成吸血鬼。这是一个，你知道，这是你暑假中相当惊人的发展。所以你匆忙赶回你的爱彼迎，开始思考我想做什么？在你离开之前，德古拉对你说，看，午夜把窗户打开，我会来找你。否则，早上就离开，永远，永远不要回来。这就像这是一个，这是一个仅此一次的选择，如果你成为吸血鬼，你就永远无法回头。所以当你反思时，你开始查找关于吸血鬼的信息，并开始给你的朋友打电话和他们谈论这件事，你发现他们所有人都已经变成了吸血鬼。所以当然，在对他们感到生气之后
for not telling you before, you say, well, why didn't you tell me? And they say, well, you can't possibly understand. You just can't understand what it's like to be a vampire. You wouldn't know what to make of it. You just have to become one. And of course, they all tell you that it's fabulous and that you should do it. And so you go, well, maybe I should do it.
因为之前没有告诉你，你说，好吧，为什么不告诉我？他们说，好吧，你不可能理解。你只是无法理解成为吸血鬼是什么感觉。你不会知道该怎么处理它。你只需要成为一个。当然，他们都告诉你这太棒了，你应该这样做。所以你心想，也许我应该这样做。
You keep thinking about it. And then you realize, well, wait a minute, if I can't possibly understand what it's like to be a vampire, then on what basis can I meaningfully and rationally like evaluate this as an option and compare it against what it's like to be human to make my choice? I haven't got the information I need. You're supposed to be able to like compare the happiness of the person after the choice to the happiness of the person before the choice. But if you've
你一直在思考它。然后你意识到，好吧，等一下，如果我不可能理解成为吸血鬼是什么感觉，那么我有什么依据可以有意义且理性地评估这作为一个选项，并将其与作为人类的感觉进行比较来做出选择？我没有我需要的信息。你应该能够比较选择后的人的幸福感与选择前的人的幸福感。但如果你
basically replaced the person, then this comparison doesn't really make any sense anymore. I'm wondering, Laurie, you know, how we should think about something like advanced directives. In medicine, you know, we ask people, you know, tell us what you would like us to do if you were in this situation. If you were in a vegetative state, if your brain wasn't working anymore, if your limbs weren't working anymore, how much, how aggressive do you want us to be? Tell us what you want and it essentially is asking people, tell me what you want done with your future self. What is the work on transformative experience? Tell us
基本上已经替换了那个人，那么这种比较就不再有任何意义了。劳里，我想知道，你知道，我们应该如何看待预先指示之类的东西。在医学上，你知道，我们要求人们，你知道，告诉我们如果你处于这种情况你会希望我们做什么。如果你处于植物人状态，如果你的大脑不再工作了，如果你的四肢不再工作了，你希望我们有多积极？告诉我们你想要什么，这本质上是在要求人们，告诉我你希望你的未来自我被如何对待。关于变革性体验的研究是什么？告诉我们
about how we should approach medical advanced directives. I think it tells us that the ordinary approach that we have towards advanced directives in some deep way really doesn't work. In other words, if you think of an advanced directive as something that you would use to make a decision about your future self, like, so for example, let's say you're a committed vegetarian and so you specify that, you know, and you've been diagnosed with Alzheimer's and it's coming on fast. So you specify that like you're not to be given bacon no matter how much you want
关于我们应该如何对待医疗预先指示。我认为它告诉我们，我们对待预先指示的普通方法在某种深层意义上确实行不通。换句话说，如果你把预先指示看作是你用来为你的未来自我做决定时会使用的东西，比如，假设你是一个坚定的素食主义者，所以你指定，你知道，而且你被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病，而且病情发展很快。所以你指定，无论你多么想要
it when you're living in your assisted living facility. Or you know, maybe you're very religious and you specify that you need to be taken to church, you know, or taken to a place where you can worship on a regular basis. And then what can happen in these contexts is you lose your commitment to vegetarianism. Everyone around you has bacon and sausage every morning. What you're committed to is enjoying various kinds of gustatory experiences, and you are deeply miserable
当你住在辅助生活设施时，你都不应该被给予培根。或者你知道，也许你非常虔诚，你指定你需要被带到教堂，你知道，或者被带到一个你可以定期礼拜的地方。然后这些语境中可能发生的事情是你失去了对素食主义的承诺。你周围的每个人每天早上都吃培根和香肠。你所承诺的是享受各种味觉体验，而你感到非常痛苦
about the fact that this advanced directive has like prevented you from gaining some source of pleasure and like in a life that's diminished in so many other ways. Or you lose your faith entirely and then you become incredibly upset at being forced to kind of go to these places of worship and participate in this what you regard as a farce now or something you just don't even care about. You have so little time left, you know, in the world that now you're forced to spend it engaging in these practices.
关于这个预先指示阻止了你获得某种快乐来源的事实，在一个在许多其他方面已经缩减的生活中。或者你完全失去了信仰，然后你对被迫去这些礼拜场所并参与这个你现在认为是一场闹剧或你根本不在乎的事情感到非常不安。你在世界上剩下的时间太少了，你知道，现在你被迫花时间参与这些实践。
You can see how these sorts of changes would happen. Other kinds of things happen with respect to like there can be catastrophic memory loss or a loss of agency in various ways. And the problem is that when you're trying, you can be told, well, this is a kind of change that's going to happen to you. But until you're actually experiencing that change, there are just dimensions of it that you can't predict. And the thought behind an advanced directive is that you're supposed to lay this out now
你可以看出这些变化是如何发生的。关于灾难性的记忆丧失或以各种方式丧失代理权，也会发生其他类型的事情。问题在于，当你尝试时，你可以被告知，好吧，这是一种将要发生在你身上的变化。但在你真正经历那种变化之前，它确实有一些你无法预测的维度。而预先指示背后的想法是，你应该现在就把它列出来
while you're a rational individual and make rational choices for your future self who's unable to make those rational choices. But if you're not able to actually rationally make those choices in the way that we describe because you don't know enough about the nature of that experience to assign it value in the right way or what you're going to care about in that context because you're going to change as the result of having the kind of cognitive change or the cognitive degradation that that's in store. So it seems to me that instead of asking people
当你是一个理性的个体时，为无法做出这些理性选择的未来自我做出理性选择。但如果你不能像我们描述的那样真正理性地做出这些选择，因为你对那种体验的本质了解不够，无法以正确的方式为其分配价值，或者因为你将要改变，作为拥有那种认知改变或即将到来的认知退化的结果，你不知道在那种语境下你会关心什么。所以在我看来，与其要求人们
to perform an impossible task, we should just be more flexible and not require people to have to make rational choices about their future care before they're actually embedded in that situation. Now there is a problem because sometimes people can't make choices at all, like if they're not able to speak
去执行一项不可能的任务，我们应该更灵活，不要要求人们在真正陷入那种情况之前，必须对他们未来的护理做出理性的选择。现在有一个问题，因为有时人们根本无法做出选择，比如如果他们无法说话
or they're not able to kind of advocate for themselves in various ways and I think part of the reason why people develop advanced directives is because they want their family members To have something from them that guides them and family members often feel very grateful at having this guide But again, it's not clear to me that those guides Are appropriate for the selves that result from whatever has happened, either if it's like cognitive decline or physical decline or some combination of that. So we have, you have a guide in how you're supposed to kind of make decisions for someone,
或者他们无法以各种方式为自己辩护，我认为人们制定预先指示的部分原因是他们希望他们的家庭成员能从他们那里得到一些指导他们的东西，而家庭成员通常对有这个指南感到非常感激。但同样，我不清楚这些指南是否适合于无论发生了什么（无论是认知衰退、身体衰退还是两者的某种组合）而产生的自我。所以我们有，你有一个关于你应该如何为某人做决定的指南，
but that guide was appropriate to who they were before the transformation. It doesn't fit to who they are afterwards. I think the notion of an advanced directive actually really does need to be rethought. We've discussed in different ways how we find it very difficult to imagine who our future selves are going to be, but that's at an individual level. Do you think the same thing happens at a collective level as well, Laurie? I do think it can happen at a collective level. I think, for example, when we went through a pandemic, what happened was a kind of collective discovery of the collective effects of, you know, social distancing and like not being able to do things like
但那个指南适用于他们转变之前的人。它不适合他们之后的人。我认为预先指示的概念确实需要重新思考。我们已经以不同的方式讨论了我们发现想象未来的自己会是什么样的人是多么困难，但这是在个人层面。劳里，你认为在集体层面也会发生同样的事情吗？我确实认为它可以在集体层面发生。我认为，例如，当我们经历大流行时，发生的是一种对社会疏离的集体影响的集体发现，以及无法做诸如
go to the gym or see people that you regularly saw in some kind of casual way, discover the value of casual kind of contact in lots of informal circumstances. It's changed us as individuals and it's changed us as a society. And so, and I think war can do that to a society and I think massive political upheaval and other kinds of contexts can do that. And I don't think there are any straightforward answers. I think it's also just super helpful to understand that this conceptual framework can apply and to recognize that there's an element of true unknown when that happens. I mean, the same thing can also happen with an election, can it not, Laurie, which is,
去健身房或在某种随意的方式下见到你经常见到的人，发现随意接触在许多非正式环境中的价值。它改变了我们作为个人，也改变了我们作为一个社会。所以，我认为战争可以对一个社会产生这种影响，我认为大规模的政治动荡和其他类型的语境也可以做到这一点。我不认为有任何直接的答案。我认为理解这个概念框架可以应用，并认识到当这种情况发生时存在一个真正的未知因素，这也非常有帮助。我的意思是，同样的事情也可以发生在选举中，不是吗，劳里，也就是，
you know, you're voting for a candidate or you vote for a party with some understanding or you know, you're making a prediction of what this party or the president might do in the future. But of course, it's not until you actually get there that you actually see what it's like. Well, that's right. And you know, it may be that the process of electing someone changes the person who you've elected so that what they were committed to before the election might actually change afterwards. So if the person that they are is changed by, for example, a landslide victory
你知道，你投票给一个候选人或你投票给一个政党，带着某种理解，或者你知道，你对这个政党或总统未来可能会做什么做出预测。但当然，直到你真正到达那里，你才会真正看到它是什么样子。嗯，那是对的。而且你知道，选举某人的过程可能会改变你所选举的人，以至于他们在选举前所承诺的事情在选举后可能会发生变化。所以如果他们所是的人被改变了，例如，通过压倒性的胜利
or being surrounded by people who change that person's character or commitments in various ways, then what we end up with as the result of an election process might actually be a transformed candidate, which then is gonna change the results in various ways. So sometimes we are actually given that rarest of things, a glimpse into who our future self is going to be. Tell me the story of the inventor Alfred Nobel, Laurie.
或者被那些以各种方式改变那个人的性格或承诺的人所包围，那么我们作为选举过程的结果最终得到的可能实际上是一个被改变的候选人，这反过来会以各种方式改变结果。所以有时我们确实得到了最罕见的东西，一瞥我们未来的自己会是什么样子。劳里，告诉我发明家阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔的故事。
Alfred Nobel was a chemist, an inventor, and what he invented was dynamite. And so basically he was a chemist, an inventor, and what he invented was dynamite. And so basically he was a contributor to indirectly to the deaths of many, especially when explosives are used in war. And what happened was there was a premature obituary that described him as the merchant of death. And he was horrified when he discovered this because that was not how he wanted to be remembered.
阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔是一位化学家、发明家，他发明的是炸药。所以基本上他是一位化学家、发明家，他发明的是炸药。所以基本上他间接地促成了许多人的死亡，特别是在战争中使用炸药时。发生的事情是有一份过早的讣告，将他描述为死亡商人。当他发现这一点时，他感到非常震惊，因为那不是他希望被记住的方式。
Okay. And so when he got this kind of insight, this sort of unexpected discovery of how he would be regarded by future generations, he dedicated his fortune basically to establishing the Nobel Prize, which obviously is a huge contribution to scientific discovery and innovation
好的。所以当他得到这种洞察力，这种关于他将被后代如何看待的意外发现时，他基本上将他的财富用于设立诺贝尔奖，这显然是对科学发现和创新的巨大贡献
and to our intellectual discovery more generally, and changed his legacy fundamentally. LA Paul is a philosopher at Yale University. She is the author of the book, Transformative Experience. Laurie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
以及对我们更广泛的智力发现，并从根本上改变了他的遗产。L.A.保罗是耶鲁大学的哲学家。她是《变革性体验》一书的作者。劳里，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你的邀请。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
If you love Hidden Brain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you're using an Apple device, you can sign up at apple.co. slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅，《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以在apple.co/hiddenbrain注册。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。